For the Sleeping in the Library app,
we're going to use
the flickr.galleries.getPhotos method.
Let's play around with this method
in the Flickr's API explorer before
we start coding.
Aside from the API key, this method
only has one required argument,
the gallery_id.
I've gone ahead and copy the gallery_id
you'll use in this project and
pasted it in.
Like before, we need to provide
url_m in the extras argument.
Otherwise theirs responsible had URLs
for the images we want to display.
Now let's call the method.
This is strange.
This doesn't quite look like what we had
with my public photo stream when we were
testing earlier.
And that's because we forgot to
change the response format to JSON,
and we're currently looking
at an XML response.
Now you'll notice the XML looks quite
similar to JSON, and I'm showing this on
purpose to again reinforce
the idea that data can be sent and
received in many different
formats over the network.
Let's switch this back to JSON and
then call the method again.
Now this is what we expected.
These results are almost identical to
what we saw with my public photo stream.
But how are we going to get
this data loaded into our app?
Well, my recommendation is that
we start with the URL itself,
the one that we see here on the bottom.
Let's copy it and
look at it piece by piece.
Everything leading up to
the question mark specifies the API.
Then after the question mark,
we have a series of argument names
followed by equal signs and their value.
Each argument value pair is
separated also by an ampersand.
I'm going to fix this URL by removing
the last argument value because it's
only necessary in the API explorer.
For the Sleeping In The Library app we
just need these argument value pairs.
And remember,
when you build your version of the app,
you'll need to use your own API
key because the one provided here
is just a temporary one
given by the API explorer.
Now let's test a URL like this using
the Postman tool that we saw earlier.
And the results look good.
These are essentially the same results
that we had in the API explorer,
except they're formatted
a little bit nicer.
And with that I think we're ready
to get started doing this in code.